Miriam asks hello Lex in your interview
with Arianna you have mentioned that
suffering is good for the soul where did
that come from what is your belief
system for maintaining self-discipline
and strong character no matter what I
think a lot of that is quite personal in
the sense that you have to know yourself
what's the distribution of energy levels
that you have like how what makes you
lazy what makes you excited what makes
you motivate it I think that's different
from person person but there are several
things I could say I think for me
right to do something difficult everyday
something I don't want to do I really
if you
when your mind your ear to the moments
where you don't really feel like doing
it do it those those kinds of things I
think train your mind in the right kind
of way to take on the things in your
life that you know you should be doing
but are hard and so you try to avoid
them I mean just training that muscle
not on real things but everyday on
things as silly as a for example
sometimes I'll take a freezing cold
shower I usually kind of ask myself is
this something I really don't feel like
doing right now and I never really feel
like doing a cold shower but there's
some days where I really don't want to
and that's what I'll do it and I'll
stand under the water for at least one
minute just freezing cold sometimes it
could be as silly as you're feeling down
but and you go to like a sigh I go to a
Starbucks and then you don't feel like
smiling or being friendly but you do it
that that I I don't feel like doing it
and I do it so this is practicing that
muscle exercise hekia every every single
day I don't really especially running I
don't like running that's why I do it
I I don't especially don't like starting
to run getting out there starting to run
the first mile first two miles is it
something that I don't want to do in the
moment and I do it
I think that's those little moments you
know it sounds dramatic to call that
suffering but it really is discomfort
struggle that trains your mind in the
way that in other things that you are
deeply passionate about that are
long-term parts of your life allows you
to pursue them long-term through the
dark parts through the struggle through
the suffering of mental and physical so
mental is the self-doubt you know
there's so many days that wake up full
of doubt and I think those days those
moments are not something you can take
on without practice
it's especially if you do difficult
things especially if you do things that
are not traditional or so on but really
everybody hits the wall often enough if
you do something big I think that's
something you have to take serious in
you have to practice and practice and
practice and a big part of practice at
least for me is habits so most things I
have noticed myself getting good at and
most things I care about that I want to
solve are things I do every day without
exception
to me to me it's better to do something
for one minute a day every day without
exception then then doing it once a
month for entire day I think there's
something about that ritual that
multiplies your minds ability to to
really take on the fold depths of
whatever the task is
you